on revient sur la une du téléjournal ce
soir cet immense tromperie de la part de
volkswagen qui a admis avoir implanté
dans ses voitures au diesel on le
souligne sa touche que les voitures au
diesel que c'est quand même le quart de
la production de volkswagen bref d'avoir
implanté un logiciel pour truquer les
données sur les émissions polluantes
la compagnie a du sein c'est la vente de
certaines ses véhicules au canada aux
états unis
l'action a chuté de près gerald nous en
parlait de près de 20% aujourd'hui ça
c'est 21 milliards de dollars donc la
valeur de cette chute avec moi yan cimon
vous êtes professeur à la faculté des
sciences de l'administration de
l'université laval spécialiste du
secteur de l'automobile messieurs simon
avez vous déjà vu ou quel autre quand
vous avez en tête d'une tromperie comme
ça dans le secteur automobile et sont
très très rares faut bien le dire parce
qu'elle est grand rappelle qu'on a vu
dans le monde de l'automobile dont on a
vu gm et les démarreurs on a vu toyota
la [ __ ] d'accélération et on en a vu
plusieurs petits entre ces rappels là
mais un cas où ce geste là est posée
sciemment je dois avouer que c'est très
très très rare peut-être même une
première même si c'est mais monsieur
sinon est-ce que à votre avis si un
petit groupe d'employés en recherche et
développement chez volkswagen qui sont
devenus fous ou si vraiment délibérée de
haut en bas
dans la hotte gestion je veux dire de
dire on va tromper les gens
on le sait passe et c'est ce qu'une
enquête démontre à lui on dit chez
volkswagen qui aurait une enquête
on a bien hâte de voir les résultats de
cette enquête là parce que monsieur
winter corps n'était président de la
division de volkswagen qui est soupçonné
d'avoir posé ces gestes là pour les
années où les véhicules ont été
mentionnés le fameux 2 millions de
véhicules aux états unis et donc on
devrait en savoir plus évidemment si
c'est un acte délibéré qui vient
directement de la haute direction
là ça pose des questions très profonde
sur la culture organisationnelle sur les
objectifs qui sont fixés à l'entreprise
à tous les paliers hiérarchique et que
ce soit en recherche et développement au
niveau des ventes
notamment mais il faudra voir où ça
s'est fait dans la chaîne
peut-être que c'est des gens qui sont au
niveau intermédiaire dans l'entreprise
qui avait certains types de pression et
qu'ils ont trouvé cette échappatoire là
pour rapidement livré la marchandise à
leurs gestionnaires supérieur mais quoi
qu'il en soit il ya un sérieux examen de
conscience à faire chez volkswagen
une sérieuse démarche aussi la voix du
côté éthique dans cette entreprise là si
les faits sont avérés commission
présentée parce que encore une fois on a
vu des défauts techniques majeures sur
des véhicules ça s'est produit dans
l'histoire mais un échappatoire comme ça
et un geste si peu éthiques posés
sciemment délibéré ont comprend pas de
calculs de l'entreprise
parce que toyota pour les pédales
n'était pas délibéré ce à dire qu'on
avait cette malle fonction pas une
erreur c'est l'île du travail mal fait
soit mais là on parle d'un geste
délibéré pour tromper les autorités
américaines dans ce cas-ci canadienne
également donc nord américaine est ce
que ça peut faire en sorte que le
premier constructeur mondial volkswagen
vraiment fier de la vitesse et on se
retrouve dans deux trois ans avec avec
une autre compagnie beaucoup plus
petites et fragiles
c'est un risque tout à fait parce que
déjà on parle de quelle est la cible de
ventes aux états unis de toutes les
marques de volkswagen se situe à 1
million de véhicules cette année et on
peut mettre une croix là-dessus on
regardait aussi don du côté d'autres
juridictions que les juridictions
américaines qui elle aussi regardent
attentivement les résultats de tests de
volkswagen maintenant sur ses modèles là
donc c'est pour avoir des répercussions
très importantes à l'inter de volkswagen
on se rappellera que le président dans
l'année qui vient normalement elle
devrait avoir une sorte d' étape au
cours de laquelle on révise ses
conditions de travail son contrat et ça
se pourrait qu'on choisisse de ne pas le
renouveler
après les résultats des enquêtes
internes et ça c'est très important
parce que bon on a une entreprise qui
avait des marques comme à audi qui
aimait se mettre à l'avant-plan sur le
côté technique et là on montre aux
consommateurs qui ont utilisé cette
technique là pour à la fois trompé de
réguler
thor et tromper le consommateur final
c'est un peu triste et déroutant d'un
point de vue 2015 là et c'est d'autant
déroutant que volkswagen se faisait se
voulait se démarquer comme une
entreprise éco-responsable une nouvelle
usine au tennessee aux états unis en
voyez vous c'est comme ça qu'on fabrique
les nouvelles voitures plus vert plus
mais donc c'est un échec épouvantable
oui il usine de chattanooga d'ailleurs
c'était une usine qui est un modèle
environnemental elle a obtenu la plus
haute certification environnementale et
on parle d'une entreprise qui a dépensé
pour reconstruire et réhabiliter
certains habitats certaines creek dans
la région usine se situe et qui pensait
aux petits détails dans sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement chez ses
fournisseurs et qui a forcé au fonds
beaucoup de gens dans la chaîne à faire
des compromis nature environnementale
qui est normal dans le contexte actuel
mais ensuite de tricher sur des
véhicules individuels qui sont vendus
aux consommateurs et de manière disons
un peu caché cette façon là parce que
lorsque vous achetez le véhicule vous
n'étiez pas conscients qu'il y avait ce
logiciel là à double usage
donc c'est un peu discutable et ce n'est
pas financier ça va leur faire très très
mal aussi puisque penser au coût des
amendes penser au coût des recours
légaux et penser au coût des différentes
juridictions qui elle aussi voudront se
faire confiance et donc c'est pas fini
sur papier jan perdu 21 milliards borges
aujourd'hui on verra la suite des shows
20 secondes monsieur simon je vous
laisse aller après est ce que c'est la
pointe de l'iceberg est ce que peut-être
cadeaux aux entreprises qui jouent comme
ça dans les voitures avec les logiciels
écoutez c'est possible mais c'est peu
probable c'est à dire qu'il ya tellement
d'organismes indépendants des gens comme
consumer report ou même des groupes
d'ingénieurs qui par plaisir se plaisent
à tester les capacités de leur
automobile et à partager ces données là
sur internet qui a encore une fois ça
rend d'autant plus la tricherie est un
autre parce que
elle est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui à découvrir qu'il ya 20 ou
30 ans par exemple
mais ce ciment merci pour cette entrevue
c'est fascinant à suivre on va suivre
cette histoire là merci ça m'a fait
plaisir une fois rivera